es el último país de suramérica en
iniciar la vacunación contra el hobby de
a uruguay llegaron 192 mil dosis de
corona bag la vacuna elaborada por el
laboratorio chino sinovac y el personal
médico que estará a cargo de la
vacunación de la población en general a
partir de este lunes fue el primero en
recibirla el gobierno estableció como
grupo prioritario al de trabajadores de
servicios esenciales docentes policías
bomberos y militares una semana después
el turno será para los profesionales de
la salud los residentes y funcionarios
de casas para adultos mayores así como
habitantes de refugios y cárceles y
quienes padecen de enfermedades crónicas
el cronograma termina con los demás
adultos mayores y el resto de la
población se espera que el 15 de marzo
se sumen otros 16 millones de dosis de
corona uac y para entre el 8 de marzo y
el 26 de abril se prevé la llegada de
460 mil dosis de país ser variante de un
total de 38 millones adquiridas a estos
dos laboratorios otros 15 millones de
vacunas provienen de la plataforma
kóvacs creada por la organización
mundial de la salud para distribuir
entre los países menos favorecidos
el plan nacional de vacunación coincide
con el primer año de mandato del
presidente luis lacalle pou el
mandatario pasó con relativo éxito su
primera prueba en el poder muchos vieron
adecuado su manejo de la crisis
sanitaria aunque algunos otros lo
critican por liderar un amplio recorte
presupuestal